[Music]  Peter are you sure you know what you're  doing yeah never stopped me before  [Music]  wait didn't you try to eat me  show me your teeth do you like a goblak  how are you so good to see you it looks  like there's a new owner this guy this  is our land hello I'm Thomas McGregor  these gates are incredibly sturdy I just  need to keep the wildlife out where they  belong in London we find vermin and we  exterminate them we're about to find out  no mrs. tiggy-winkle stop look away this  is our ancestors land it's time to get  our garden back we're gonna need  everyone calm down  Benjamin  [Music]  the greater lesson  things are not done to end well for you  no guts no glory it's time to bring the  fight to him let's have a hold wait -  boys get along perfectly and that's what  separates us from the French our natural  rabbit space should be able to keep up  do you know what that would never have  worse  you  [Music]